Evelyn is in Los Angeles hi Evelyn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you I'm such a huge fan so thanks for
taking my call
vamonos el cuñado yes and so I'm a
freelance suspense for like an older
gentleman in an entertainment industry
um so I kind of looked up to him as a
mentor as he accomplished all the things
that I wanna do and so I met him at
entertainment
party and he connected me with a lot of
connections which was really nice but as
I got to know him I noticed that he was
very unprofessional and my teachings too
much apologies and it's a can see with
women I'm glad I turned overlooked that
because he did assist me a lot so
recently he came into a hard time where
he lost his house and his ex or his
accounts were frozen and so he's been
calling me a lot really to drive him
from place to place I guess looking for
a place to live and he thought oh close
to $600 from me so I even had him stay
with my friend for over a month and for
free until my friend got a lil annoyed
and asked him to leave so to me it's not
about the money that he borrowed that I
feel like he keeps promising me all
these plans things of getting this dream
job that I wanted to get and how he will
connect me with this person who's has a
job opening but that has yet to come to
fruition oh I am 25 do you have do you
have any sisters
I do what if your sister told you this
story what would you tell her well I did
tell one of my sisters bit know that one
what I asked you I said what if your
sister was doing all the stupid things
that you're doing what would you say to
her I guess I would say stop doing I
mean when you just when you spill all
this out this guy spells loser with a
capital L Dabney yeah but he did I don't
know but I'm glad he assisted you that's
nice that's nice and you gave him 600
bucks that's nice but this guy's a
parasite and you caught on to that well
recently yes I've noticed that yeah the
guy you described to me is highly
unattractive
editor yes you guys I feel bad for Donal
okay oh he has bad moral character and
he's trying to take you care take
advantage of a 25 year old young lady
yeah and this whole dirty old man is got
you running him around all over town
making you a bunch of promises he's not
going to keep and he took six hundred
bucks from you because you admire some
of the work he did a decade ago but he
in done anything smart in a while that's
true yeah and Oh should I like I guess
I'm liking it I feel like I'm more
insulted I guess yeah you should be but
you also should look in the mirror and
go I just paid $600 tuition to the
School of Life and I just learned one
more time how to identify a loser a
little bit quicker and not get myself
sideways with characters like this you
need to leave this boy alone Evelyn
you're never going to see you money this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]